[Music]
uh you guys must be new to town right
new to town but not new to the country
we just moved from California oh we just
wondered uh if you wouldn't mind if your
daughter played with our daughter Audrey
say hi
why
slides off limits to Ching chongs
cute
do you want to be best friends look at
me look at me look at me now guess who's
going back to the motherland it's a big
deal going to your birth country we used
to talk about it all the time when we're
little remember Grand Adventure to find
your birth mother so proud of you
y'all calling me crazy my translator in
Beijing Audrey I got you ready
[Laughter]
cat lives there now your famous college
roommate you ready to lose to a
celebrity
oh hi hey
come from
you know I think I get it I called the
adoption agency and she lives in hiching
okay will you guys come with me yes
I love a grand Adventure
oh hi so nice to see in America what do
you do for work it's the cops are doing
a back check
you're dropped
drug to condom we can't get caught with
drugs in China we'll get jailed for life
never come to China people are always
thinking that I have this perfect life I
don't belong anywhere if you do not know
where you come from how do you know who
you are
we could still find her our passports
are in my suitcase that got stolen you
know we can bypass the airport security
K-pop Stars everyone remember their
names sassy cutie Lisa Lisa too I don't
believe these girls are singers girls
show them
um why are we supposed to show you're a
fan of cardi B right yeah but is she
here
there's some in this house
did you get the coke bags out yeah but
only seven and I think I put in eight
just push pull I mean
but it's my